cannes au mois de mai
pendant le festival du film à la tombée
de la nuit les grands hôtels
s'illuminent pour accueillir les fêtes
les plus courues de la croisette
ce soir la soirée la plus sélect a lieu
au 7e étage de ce palace
elle est organisée par un grand
joaillier chopard une suite de 250 m²
avec terrasse et vue imprenable sur la
croisette
ici des gens riches voire très riches
venus du monde entier des jet setteur
triés sur le volet et une maîtresse de
maison
caroline chauffe le 49 ans la
coprésidente allemand de chopard
derrière son grand sourire à l'étendue à
la investi deux millions et demi d'euros
pour organiser des fêtes somptueuses
tous les soirs et privatiser les plus
belles suites de cannes
son objectif réaliser près de 20% de son
chiffre d'affaires annuel en une semaine
alors pas de temps à perdre
elle aborde chaque invité dans sa langue
maternelle caroline en parle 5
couramment l'italien l'espagnol
l'allemand et bien sûr l'anglais comment
on tient je suis trop triste
ils ont loupé l'avion ils sont restés à
londres
ses invités sont peut-être des amis mais
ce sont avant tout ses meilleurs clients
et ce soir elle compte bien leur vendre
des dizaines de bijoux comme celui ci un
collier tigre avec émeraude géante à
plus d'un million et demi d'euros pour
vendre un tel bijou les occasions comme
le festival de cannes sont extrêmement
rares un des plus gros rassemblements de
grosses fortunes
le rendez vous à ne pas rater quand on
vend des produits de luxe
pour y arriver elle doit leur faire
franchir cette porte gardée 24 heures
sur 24 et les amener jusqu'à ce canapé à
seulement quelques mètres de la piste de
danse une partie de la suite a été
spécialement aménagé en boutique
caroline et gardent sous haute sécurité
les joyaux de sa collection comme ce
petit cochon en diamant rose avec lequel
il est difficile de passer inaperçu et
qui vaut jusqu'à 5 millions d'euros une
petite fortune mais à ce prix-là c'est
aussi le sentiment d'exception que l'on
achète ces pièces uniques une fois
vendus il y aura par deuxième si vous
savez vous avez quelque chose d unique
au monde
bien sûr ça beaucoup plus ces valeurs
ils les femmes restent passé croisés
dans des soirées avec les mêmes bijoux
en plus de ces arguments et de son
brushing impeccable caroline va devoir
sortir d'autres atouts car sa marque de
joaillerie n'est pas la seule présente à
cannes et le problème c'est qu'avant de
venir à sa soirée beaucoup de clientes
ont déjà fait leurs courses chez les
concurrents
et l'autre c'est quoi là c'est chaud par
lasser van cleef la ceinture classé
vintage
ça c'est le meilleur j'achète j'achète
et je collectionne aussi à oui j'adore
ça je pense que c'est la joaillerie et
les diamants qui sont les meilleurs amis
de la femme
chopard dior chanel boucheron van cleef
ou mauboussin
aujourd'hui une dizaine de grandes
maisons se partagent le marché mondial
de la joaillerie un énorme business de
80 milliards d'euros en france ces
enseignes sont toutes installées au même
endroit autour de la place vendôme une
place proche des champs elysées et
construite par louis xiv au début du 20e
siècle
elle accueille un palace le ritz et
devient le repère des horlogers des
joaillier une adresse prestigieuse connu
dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui la guerre fait rage entre
les joaillier de la place et chacun sa
méthode pour l'emporter
ultra luxe ou carrément prix cassés
quels sont les secrets de fabrication de
ces bijoux à plusieurs millions d'euros
comment les grandes maisons s'y
prend-elle pour vendre ses parures hors
de prix et comment d'autres parviennent
ils à proposer le luxe au grand public
[Musique]
bien loin du glamour de cannes c'est au
fond de cette zone industrielle que tout
commence pour les parures à plusieurs
millions d'euros
nous sommes en suisse à quelques
kilomètres de genève dans les ateliers
du fabricant une usine coffre-fort
serrure en reconnaissance digitale
enfilade de sa sécurisé ici même la co
présidente caroline cheveux le doit
montrer patte blanche pour atteindre le
coeur de l'entreprise
la salle des pierres précieuses
ça va le luxe car l'hymne est tombé
dedans quand elle était toute petite
elle n'avait que deux ans quand ses
parents ont racheté une horlogerie de
suisse mythique fondé en 1860 par louis
ulysse chopard
aujourd'hui les parents de caroline ont
pris leur retraite avec son frère karl
c'était elle qui a lancé l'entreprise
sur le créneau de la haute joaillerie
ce matin avec son directeur de création
la coprésidente s'attelle à la
fabrication de plusieurs parure la
plupart dépasse le million d'euros alors
comment expliquer un prix aussi
exorbitants tout commence par le choix
des pierres précieuses
caroline ne sélectionne que les plus
rares les produits comme 7 émeraudes
colombiennes
je pourrais toujours traqués par 0 ou
encore ce diamant rarissime d'afrique du
sud à la couleur très particulière
ça c'est très beau c'est un diamant
cognac sommes à 7 a là on va peut-être
tous les dix ans une bière comme ça ah
oui c'est au tour de 4 millions de
dollars 4 millions de dollars jusqu'à 4
millions de dollars soit un peu plus de
3 millions d'euros
des pierres exceptionnelles comme celle
ci caroline en achète dans les mines du
monde entier par l'intermédiaire de
négociants ensuite pour habiller les
pierres il faut leur créer une parure
une étape qui nécessite le talent de
cinq dessinateurs recrutés
principalement aux beaux-arts et payer
jusqu'à 8000 euros par mois enfin
direction l'atelier de haute joaillerie
c'est ici que les dessins prennent forme
entre les mains d'une trentaine
d'orfèvre des polisseurs maquettiste ou
sertisseur touch ont suivi dix ans de
formation comme dans une maison de haute
couture la fabrication de chaque bijou
souvent en un seul exemplaire coûte une
petite fortune à l'image de cette
farandole de chat plutôt original serti
de plus de 8400 minuscule diamants
blancs et 18 améthyste
1200 heures ça capte en fait toutes
attentions de concentration d'un
bijoutier pendant plus de trois mois des
mois de travail une surenchère de
pierres précieuses et une marge
confortable
selon nos informations il pourrait
dépasser les 50% pour les pièces les
plus exceptionnels les résultats des
prix de vente hallucinant des prix que
caroline ne fixe qu'une fois le travail
terminé car chaque bijou est un
prototype dont le temps de fabrication
est impossible à déterminer précisément
à l'avance précédant les grands bureaux
pour la calculations le prêt de 150 et
[Musique]
250 mille euros à vue de nez pour ce
bracelet à ce prix là les clients
potentiels ne sont pas très nombreuses à
peine quelques centaines dans le monde
pour les séduire la concurrence est rude
entre les joaillier de la place vendôme
et c'est avant tout une guerre d'image
retour à cannes pendant le festival
le must pour faire connaître ses bijoux
c'est de les faire porter par une star
de cinéma
une actrice qui monte les marches avec
une parure autour du cou ou autour du
poignet c'est la garantie d'une
promotion mondiale est gratuite avec des
répercussions immédiates sur les ventes
un enjeu de taille alors lé joaillier
sont prêts à tout pour s'attirer les
faveurs des célébrités sur ce terrain le
joaillier suisse a pris une longueur
d'avancé sur ses concurrents
il y à 13 ans il a négocié un statut
privilégié en devenant partenaire
officiel du festival
une situation qui lui permet de mettre
en avant sa marque mais qui ne suffit
pas à lui assurer la victoire auprès des
stars
alors chaque jour il faut se battre et
ça commence dès 10h du matin au quartier
général de la marque
c'est l'heure du briefing pour la
directrice marketing raffaella rossier
l'eau sous ses ordres un bataillon
d'assistante moi je commence à vous à de
distribuer les pass est entre leurs
mains
la liste des célébrités qui défieront ce
soir sur le tapis rouge
on attend notamment les actrices kristin
scott thomas ce ou qu'elle blanche est
l'héroïne d'aviator et du dernier robin
des bois et pas seulement peut-être
emmanuelle béart
il faut se tenir prêtes pour naomi
campbell aussi pour ce soir c'était qui
le contactent cette affaire tu peux tu
peux vérifier dans l'équipe de raffaella
la course aux stars et très organisés
chaque assistante à son terrain de
chasse
ici nous allons l ena d'un mode est
selon les lomagnols la lna pour
leicester hispanique l'angleterre les uk
gaël la moiti gueule pour les
anglophones ou encore sic et autriche et
pays de l'europe de l'est
merci à tout le monde et à tout à
l'heure il faut se dépêcher car sur la
croisette
aujourd'hui elles ne seront pas les
seuls il ya beaucoup de concurrence
j'assure ya des grands voiliers dans
maisons qui sont présents à cannes
et comme nous espère que les
personnalités monte les marches avec
leurs robes bijoux bien sûr des
concurrents qui ne sont jamais bien loin
dans le même hôtel sera au ski le
spécialiste du cristal et à quelques
centaines de mètres de là quartier dior
ou encore van cleef comme si la place
vendôme s'était déplacé sur la côte
d'azur le temps du festival pour
décrocher une star il faut donc prendre
ses concurrents de vitesse et à ce petit
jeu là c'est l ena l'assistante
espagnole la plus rapide
et voici sa prise peu genia silva un
mannequin espagnol très caliente
une vraie star dans tout le monde
hispanique une clé pour conquérir
l'amérique du sud un marché en plein
boom
eugenia il fait régulièrement la une des
magazines de mode les plus prestigieux à
coup sûr ce soir elle devrait attirer
l'objectif des photographes du monde
entier
le perdant s'il vous plaît vous alors
vous allez chercher quoi il a des bijoux
ah oui
on cherche les bijoux pour faire les
choix pour l'ingénieur pour ce soir pour
que ces bijoux soient visibles de loin
la marque a déjà sélectionné pour elle
les colliers les plus gros et les plus
étincelant ce soir il faudra que ça
brille sous les flashs
le pire serait de passer inaperçu c'est
koléa qui hélas est un ps très très
importante parce que c'est un brin de
diamant
c'est un très gros diamant et sa vallée
il fait plus de 95 écoute c'était
prendre sa retraite et m quatre gardes
du corps ce soir eugenia va enchaîner
plusieurs soirées après la projection du
film
pour cela le joaillier lui prête le gros
diamant ou leur cognac à plus de 3
millions d'euros pour un cocktail sur
riot puisse est paru en émeraude à près
de 4 millions d'euros
le temps d'un dîner de milliardaires ça
vous plaît
selon nos informations la jeune
mannequin serait rémunéré pour servir de
présentoirs vivant mais ça ni elle ni la
marque
nhem en parler c'est un contrat que vous
avez avec chopard est ce qu'on entend
dans ce cadre comment ça va c'est que de
l'amitié
non je ne peux pas discuter des termes
de mon contrat avec vous non c'est
secret c'est ça oui ça y est secret on
discute jamais de ces affaires de ces
contrats privés jamais c'est normal mais
aussi à coude en baisse et risquent en
fait sous contrat non non amir là les
taux n'ont pas être content
non je suis la seule gényer silva aurait
donc bien un contrat qu'il obligerait
notamment à monter les marches avec un
bijou de la marque
ce soir ce sera cette parure en diamants
à 720 mille euros les stars vous allez
on y va dans quelques minutes
eugenia sera sur le tapis rouge et elle
ne sera pas la seule à assurer la
publicité de la marque vu l'activité qui
règne dans les couloirs du palace la
directrice marketing vient de réussir un
très gros coup elle semblerait avoir
convaincu une autre espagnole penélope
cruz
la star internationale est une fidèle de
la maison pour elle l'essayage se
déroule dans l'intimité d'un salon vip
enfin la responsable marketing des pays
de l'est a elle aussi bien fait son
travail elle a mis dans sa poche et
verrerie gauvard sur la terrasse du
palace le célèbre mannequin tchèque
couple séance d'essayage et shooting
photo mais là encore impossible de
savoir ce qu'elle a obtenu en
contrepartie 19 heures c'est le moment
pour eugenia le mannequin espagnol de
faire son festival et elle va se révéler
d'une redoutable efficacité pendant près
de trois minutes
eugenia enchaîne les poses et focalise
sur ses plus beaux atours l'attention de
centaines de photographes
résultat c'est dans l'indifférence la
plus totale que les autres invités
rejoignent la salle de projection
en misant sur elle le joaillier suisse
vient de réussi un très gros coup et ce
n'est pas le seul au total en dix jours
de festival
ce sont près de 70 stars comme naomi
watts l'héroïne de king kong qui ont
assuré la promotion de la marque ne
laissant que très peu de place à la
concurrence
alors cette occupation du terrain at
elle fonctionné
la réponse près de genève au siège
social du fabricant suisse
trois semaines après la fin du festival
c'est l'heure du verdict pour caroline
cheveux et sa directrice marketing leur
stratégie de communication
c'est elle avérée payante ça c'est la
france des photos dans les journaux
français mais aussi chinois grecs ou
espagnols avec eugenia silva qui
s'affiche en pleine page dans le plus
célèbre magazine people d'espagne son
collier de diamants rien en vue une
diffusion mondiale et sans débourser un
centime
si elle avait dû payer l'équivalent de
cépages en publicité ça leur aurait
coûté une petite fortune pour vous
donner une idée l'année dernière on a eu
un équivalent de retombées médiatiques
que pour à peu près 14 millions d'euros
ah bon
oui c'est non 14 millions d'euros de
budget publicitaire économisés grâce à
une opération cannoise qui leur en a
coûté cinq fois moins une affaire très
rentable
de quoi leur donner le sourire en ces
temps de crise car depuis quelques
années en effet la place vendôme a
mauvaise mine
moins de monde devant les vitrines des
boutiques boudés par les acheteurs
l'année dernière certaines maisons ont
annoncé une baisse de leur chiffre
d'affaires allant jusqu'à 20%
comme la plupart des grandes enseignes
de luxe chopard a été rattrapé par la
crise dans ce contexte morose une seule
marque s'en sort haut la main en
affichant des résultats records
mauboussin + 40 % de chiffre d'affaires
en 2009 pour faire exploser ses ventes
le joaillier parisien a misé sur une
stratégie totalement inédite place
vendôme rendre le luxe accessible en
cassant les prix
ce samedi après midi c'est la fête des
mères
et on se bouscule au portillon
bizarrement c'est arthur way
il y a la queue devant la boutique une
demi-heure d'attentes et à l'intérieur
on se croirait presque à la caisse d'un
supermarché un événement jamais vu place
vendôme
ah oui vraiment je surprise vous écoutez
je crois que c'est seul magasin de la
place vendôme où il ya autant
on a fait tous préfèrent plutôt calme
ces livraisons
ce qui a attiré autant de monde
aujourd'hui c'est un énorme coup
marketing des publicités dans le métro
un sacrilège dans l'univers feutré de la
joaillerie de luxe
d'autant plus que la marque cassent les
prix et les affiche en gros caractères
comme s'il s'agissait de jambon ou
d'aspirateurs 750 euros pour une
alliance en diamant 395 euros pour une
montre en nacre et brillants résultats
ceux qui font la queue aujourd'hui sont
loin d'être milliardaire pour la plupart
c'est l'une des premières fois qu'ils
osent franchir la porte d'un bijoutier
de luxe comme bertrand huissier de
justice et sa compagne joséphine femme
au foyer
madame a repéré cette bague en topaz
serti de petits diamants à 1720 euros il
s'était fixé dans les 2000 euros
c'est donc dans leur budget c'est bien
ma taille
il correspond pourtant madame hésite
encore qu'est ce t'en penses
moi je trouve très unis ce qui va les
faire craquer c'est un petit détail ici
toutes les bagues ont un nom taillé sur
mesure pour les amoureux de toi c'est
fou de toi mais l'autre argument de choc
se trouve à la caisse une promotion
spéciale comme en proposent les grandes
surfaces résultat une bague à moins de
1500 euros
mais à ce prix on n'est pas la seule à
la portée
al'inverse de la haute joaillerie comme
chez chopard ici la plupart des modèles
sont produits à des milliers
d'exemplaires jusqu'à 40000 pour ce
diamant le best seller de la marque est
aujourd'hui encore la fête des mères va
se révéler un véritable carton
commercial 2 millions d'euros de
recettes c'est plus de 5% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'année réalisé en
seulement quelques jours
alors comment ce grand joaillier
parisien fait-il pour casser ses prix
aujourd'hui la place vendôme ne parle
que de cet homme le patron de mauboussin
alain nemarq 57 ans le vilain petit
canard de la place vendôme son succès
fascine autant qu'il irrite le monde des
joaillier car alain nemarq mais pas du
sérail vous y connaissez quelque chose a
vraiment rien a remarqué ça n'a pas
beaucoup changé
alain nemarq n'est pas l'héritier d'une
dynastie de bijoutiers mais un ancien
professeur de marketing à hec la plus
grande école de commerce spécialisé dans
la restructuration d'entreprises en
difficulté il a commencé sa carrière de
redresseur au début des années 80 en
relançant un grand fabricant de
moquettes
il a ensuite fait carrière dans la mode
à la tête de kenzo ou encore dit saint
laurent il y a neuf ans on l'appelle à
la tête de mauboussin car l'entreprise
est en pleine crise elle perd 30
millions d'euros par an là c'est la prod
pour éviter le dépôt de bilan
il va alors prendre des mesures
radicales en six mois il réduit les
effectifs au strict minimum
244 l'entreprise passe à seulement 23
salariés et pour augmenter la
productivité il remplace tous les chefs
de service comme ici épartement
transport et dwan savoir que quand moi
je suis arrivé ils étaient deux
j'ai pas les mêmes et ils traitaient
3000 pièces par an ils sont toujours
deux c'est pas les mêmes et on va
traiter cette année 70 mille pièces par
an mt vivian
restructurations fermetures de boutiques
déficitaire à monaco ou londres
au total alain nemarq que réalise près
de 17 millions d'économies en à peine un
an le seul service où il ne rechigne pas
à la dépense c'est ici au marketing la
publicité dans le métro plutôt qu'au
festival de cannes c'était son idée ça
c'est une vraie révolution
et ce n'est pas la seule technique
commerciale il est emprunté à la grande
distribution
chaque mois à l'année marque organise en
effet des promos comme au supermarché
là nous avions l'opération galette des
rois fête des rois nous invitions nos
clients avec une alors c'était très
amusant c'était une petite réduction qui
correspondait à la fève qu'ils allaient
trouver dans la galette donc falloir
avait beaucoup plus à ces thèmes et la
galette des rois
la fête des mères ou encore la saint
valentin ça lui suffit pas il faut qu'il
invente au moins une fête pour les deux
mois
et pour ça il ne manque pas d'idées
avons un président qui est très créatif
qui nous avait c'était les demoiselles
tatin pour déguster de délicieuses
tartes tatin et là nous allons c'était
l'espoir à l'occasion du solstice d'été
une classe elle existe dorénavant des
promos des pub dans le métro
le coup de génie d'alain nemarq c'est
d'avoir sorti le business du luxe de son
ghetto de riches un ghetto où il était
enfermé depuis près de deux siècles
comme tous les joies y ait de la place
vendôme la maison mauboussin créée en
1827 a bâti sa fortune en vendant des
colliers ultra luxueux comme celui ci à
une poignée de richissimes clients le
plus fidèle a longtemps été le sultan de
brunei l'un des hommes les plus riches
du monde est un symbole de la jet set
dans les années 90 la marque va devenir
dépendant de cette énorme clients qui
représente à lui tout seul 80% du
chiffre d'affaires
mais en 2000 catastrophe le sultan
rencontrent des difficultés financières
et stoppe net ses commandes pour
mauboussin tout s'effondre
appelés pour sauver la maison de la
faillite l'ancien prof de marketing a
retenu la leçon
exit les sultans et autres milliardaires
avec son directeur de production il
décide de cibler une clientèle beaucoup
plus large
à chaque nouvelle collection les deux
hommes ont le même impératif proposer
des bagues à moins de 3000 euros
un seuil psychologique selon ce
spécialiste du marketing
c'est important de savoir vos objets
doivent être beaucoup en dessous 3000
euros ensuite il faut qu'ils en aient en
dessous de 1000 euros pendant parmi
ceux-là mais c'est surtout le fait
qu'une femme achète à peu près
spontanément des objets jusqu'à 2000
euros sans avoir forcément besoin
d'avoir l'aval de son compagnon de son
mari et chrétiens ici c'est donc le
patron qui fixe les prix à l'avance le
directeur de production doit s'adapter
même avant de dessiner l'objet on
connaît déjà son prix de vente donc un
mois de descendre après tout la toute la
cascade de prix j'avais pris de métal
vous avez pris des pierres la main
d'oeuvre main d'oeuvre matières
premières vous allez le voir la marque
additionne les petites économies pour
proposer des bijoux jusqu'à 40% moins
cher que ses concurrents de la place
vendôme
ça commence dès le dessin et la surprise
pas de grosses équipes artistiques comme
chez chopard
ici c'est le patron lui-même qui s'y
colle et tout se joue en deux coups de
crayons aux bijoux je vais le fabriquer
le telle manière à vous à limiter mon
poids devant ici quand vous regardez
l'intérieur de la pièce où vous voyez
qu'il essaie en creux
j'aurais pu faire en plein on va pouvoir
gagner 2 g 3 or 2 ou 3 grammes d'or en
moins sur chaque bague
ça n'a l'air de rien mais c'est une
petite fortune
car depuis cinq ans le cours de l'or a
explosé il a été multiplié par 3 2 ou 3
grammes d'or en moins
sont entre 60 et 90 euros d'économisés
sur chaque bague et ce n'est pas la
seule astuce pour réduire la facture
pour le savoir nous avons fait
expertiser plusieurs bagues de la
nouvelle collection mauboussin par
lysiane bouquet cette spécialiste
reconnu des pierres précieuses a
travaillé pour la plupart des grands
joaillier de la place vendôme
pendant près de 20 ans pour elle c'est
aussi grâce aux choix des pierres cas
l'année marque ferez baisser ses coûts
de fabrication pour comprendre prenons
un exemple
c'est pierre violette les améthystes
leur prix varie en fonction de
l'intensité de la couleur
plus la couleur est intense
plus la mitis tas de valeur dans des
clercs comme celle ci ça va dans les 10
euros du carat et là ça peut aller dans
les 30 euros du cara d'accord voilà donc
c'est du simple au triple à et pour
cette bague l'améthyste le choisis par
le fabricant serait l'une des plus
claires du marché selon la spécialiste
alors là très très clair maintenant tous
les goûts sont dans la nature
et ça peut être très agréable de porter
une amitié très clair qu'il ya un
soupçon de couleurs et qui va avec tout
en fait j'aurais moins véloce qui aura
donc y aura beaucoup moins de myers et
certains des pierres parmi les moins
coûteuses du marché quelques grammes
d'eau en moins de recettes de
fabrication qui permet de faire baisser
le prix de revient
le troisième secteur où l'on peut
réduire les coûts c'est la fabrication
alain nemarq ne s'en est jamais caché
aujourd'hui il fait certes hier la
quasi-totalité de ses bijoux en inde en
chine et en thaïlande des pays où la
main d'oeuvre est beaucoup moins cher
qu'en france
en plus il n'hésite pas à rogner sur ses
marges
résultat toutes ses économies
additionnelles lui permettre de proposer
des bijoux à prix cassés tout en ayant
pignon sur rue place vendôme qu'on en
avait enfin devant st
vingt-et-une nouvelle boutique depuis le
début de l'année plus de 40 millions de
chiffre d'affaires en 2009 grâce à sa
stratégie à bas prix le patron affiche
aujourd'hui une insolente réussite
de quoi savourer sa revanche sur les
vieilles maisons de la place qui n'ont
rien à ses débuts en fait je sais pas
exactement ce que c'est qu'un concurrent
[Musique]
moi je n'en vois pas moi j'en veux plus
alain nemarq s'est fixé un objectif
doubler son chiffre d'affaires d'ici
en plus des boutiques traditionnelles il
vient de lancer son site de vente en
ligne sur internet
ultime provocation le turbulent patrons
s'y amusent à inventer une station de
métro baptisé place vendôme
[Musique]